we have taken cells from the carcass of
an animal that died decades ago and
brought them back to life and so it is
possible using today's technology to
take body's carcasses of animals that
died decades ago and resurrect them in
the form of clones now we have also
sequenced the genes of the Neanderthal
man meaning that at some point in the
future it may be possible to bring back
the Neanderthal man
in fact at Harvard University a one
professor even made a proposal as to how
much it would cost to reassemble the
genome of the Neanderthal man and then
of course if a young Neanderthal boy is
born then the question is where do you
put the boy in a zoo or at Harvard this
is a question that we're going to be
facing in the coming decades because it
is possible that we might be able to
bring back the mammoths we're talking
about creatures that walk the surface of
the earth tens of thousands of years ago
and we have their genome and it's a
series proposal now now that we're
closing in on sequencing all the genes
of a mammoth to bring the mammoths by
inserting a fertilized egg inside the
womb of an elephant and having an
elephant give birth to a to a mammoth
now dinosaurs are much more difficult
they perished 65 million years ago not
tens of thousands of years ago however
something has happened that I thought
would not happen in my lifetime and that
is we have soft tissue from the
dinosaurs I never thought it would be
possible in my lifetime if you take a
hadrosaur and crack open the thigh bones
bingo you find soft tissue right there
in the bone marrow who would have
thought t-rex is - and scientists have
analyzed not the DNA but the proteins
inside the soft tissue not surprisingly
we find the proteins of chickens and
also frogs and reptiles which means of
course the dinosaurs we can now show
biochemically are very closely related
to birds in fact
birds are dinosaurs that survived the
Cataclysm of 65 million years ago now
there is another proposal you to use
what is called epigenetics nature does
not simply throw away good genes nature
simply turns them off for example we
have the genes in our own body that
would put hair all over our body and you
can actually turn that gene on and
create quote-unquote a werewolf in fact
in Mexico City there are two young boys
with hair all over their bodies that are
acrobats in in a circus and scientists
have sequenced the genes and yes it is a
very ancient gene that they have with
chickens we can actually see the genes
for chickens that were turned off
because of epigenetics genes they give
webbing between the toes of a chicken
because a long time ago chickens had
webbed feet and also teeth you can
actually bring back teeth inside
chickens so then the question is is it
possible to make the next big leap to
use epigenetics to use gene therapy to
use all the different kinds of therapies
we have mix all these things up in the
memory of a computer ok and have the
computer give the best fit for a reptile
that is like a dinosaur insert that
perhaps into the womb of maybe an
alligator or whatever and perhaps give
birth to an egg which will hatch
something resembling a dinosaur well
that's not possible today but it's not
out of the question
it's not out of the question that at
some point in the future we'll use a
computer to take all these bits of DNA
from living lizards from the extracting
information from the proteins of soft
tissue from hadrosaurs and assemble the
best mathematical approximation to a
dinosaur and have it give birth to an
egg
you